mind your decisions i'm preshtal walker
solve for real values of x such that 3
to the power of 2x plus 1
plus 4 multiplied by 3 to the power of x
minus 15 is equal to zero
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
a problem like this looks intimidating
but don't give up
you can solve it
to get started we will analyze the
leading term of three to the power of
two x plus one
we will break it up into two terms
this will be equal to three to the power
of 2x
multiplied by 3 to the power of 1.
3 to the power of 1 is equal to 3
so this is equal to 3
multiplied by 3 to the power of 2x
we will substitute that into the leading
term
next let's take a look at 3 to the power
of x
you can solve it
we will write u as equal to 3 to the
power of x
we will substitute that in
now we will square both sides of this
equation so u squared is equal to three
to the power of two x
we can then substitute that in right
here
the problem now reduces to a quadratic
equation in u
three u squared plus four u minus
fifteen is equal to zero
you can solve this with the quadratic
formula or we can try our luck with
factoring
as luck would have it we can factor this
equation pretty easily it will be equal
to three u minus five multiplied by u
plus three
we get two solutions
one is u is equal to five over three and
the other is u is equal to negative
three
now recall that u is equal to three to
the power of x
but 3 to the power of x is greater than
0 for real values of x
therefore we can eliminate the solution
u is equal to negative 3.
we thus have u is equal to 5 over 3 and
u is equal to three to the power of x
thus three to the power of x is equal to
five over three
we now need to solve this equation for x
we'll take the natural log of both sides
the x will come out to the front
we will then divide both sides of the
equation by the natural log of 3.
thus x is equal to the natural log of 5
over 3 all over the natural log of 3 and
that's approximately equal to 0.46
and that's the answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on youtube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve the world's problems one video at
a time
[Music]